-Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now.
This week, former president
Trump was arrested
and charged here in New York.
Plus --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, Easter is on Sunday.
The new "Super Mario Bros."
movie is now in theaters.
And I just heard the NBA
says it will no longer
test players for weed.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, Trump's arrest.
He's facing 34 charges
related to hush-money payments.
He's in real trouble, and every
time he opens his mouth
to talk about the case,
his lawyers say...
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
That's who Easter's all about.
Families come together
to celebrate.
And of course, on Sunday,
the Easter Bunny
will show up and shout,
"It's a-me."
That's Mario's catchphrase.
And you can hear it in the all
new "Super Mario Bros. Movie."
I hope there's a scene
on Rainbow Road,
flying down that colorful track
makes you feel...
high as a kite.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you can be
in the NBA
because they're no longer
testing players for marijuana.
It's crazy to think
a couple years ago
smoking weed
could land you...
in jail.
[ Laughter ]
Trump pled not guilty
on Tuesday,
but as the judge
read the charges,
it became pretty clear that his
best legal defense is to...
pray.
[ Laughter ]
I really hope the Easter Bunny
brings me
some Easter chocolate
and marshmallow Peeps.
That would be so...
dope.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, marijuana
is fair game now.
So after every game, the teams
are gonna head to White...
Castle -- that's where
Peach lives -- in a castle.
This movie can make
175 million bucks
in one weekend.
Wow.
Nobody's made so much money
in so little time since...
Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter ]
Trump gave her hush money
for their one-night stand,
but she still told everyone that
his junk looks like...
a mushroom, kind of like Toad,
who's in the movie,
and so is Yoshi.
Maybe we'll see him hatch from
one of his famous green...
eggs.
Kids put them
in their Easter baskets,
along with candy, presents
and, of course...
grass.
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion, karts are driven,
big decision, he is risen.
Have fun in prison.
This has been
a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]